email marketing is a great way of
building relationships between the
businesses and its customers more and
more companies understand the importance
of email marketing it is one of the most
effective ways to acquire new customers
communicate with the existing ones and
boost sales reaching your audience with
an effective email marketing campaign is
crucial to almost every online business
many tools can help you with this task
but it is important to choose the best
and affordable tool for your business
hey everyone i am tasha badiwal welcome
to simply learns youtube channel in this
video we will explore the best email
marketing tools that will help you to
grow your business but before we begin
if you enjoy watching tech related
content consider subscribing to our
youtube channel and hitting that bell
icon to stay tuned
so before we move on to the list what
form of marketing do you think is the
best
let us know in the comment section below
so let's start with the first and the
most famous tool on our list which is
mailchimp
mailchimp is a comprehensive marketing
platform that helps you track off and
communicate with your clients customers
and other interested parties but it's
popular because of its email services
whenever you are launching a new product
driving sales or making an announcement
mailchimp's powerful feature will help
you to do it right
email marketing tool mailchimp is
probably the most well known in terms of
what it offers the price is really
affordable it also offers a pretty solid
a b testing feature allowing you to test
different subject lines and email
designs there is a free plan of
mailchimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses up to
2000 subscribers can be added
and 12 000 emails can be sent in a month
it supports multiple integration to
integrate other third party softwares
and mailchimp also offers you to update
or remove the subscriber's profile which
is also one of the best feature of
mailchimp
now let's discuss some pros of mailchimp
the free plan is valid forever up to
2000 contacts campaigns can easily build
and customized reporting that helps
optimize the future sense
now let's discuss the cons of mailchimp
larger contact list over 50k subscribers
are more expensive
phone support is very limited it is not
designed for advanced marketing teams
so let's discuss the pricing of
mailchimp so basically mailchimp comes
up with the four plans one is free on
free plan you will get some good
features if you want a b testing then
you can go with the essential plan if
you want to use some custom templates
then you can go with the standard plan
and in premium plan you will get a phone
and priority support so if you want that
you can go with that and some more
additional features you will get in the
premium plan
next up we have active campaign
active campaign is a customer experience
automation software that facilitates
email marketing due to the fact that it
is designed to manage contacts and sales
processes it is powerful email marketing
automation tool with many features you
need automation to save time and money
if you have a large email list you need
to be able to create drip campaigns
automatically send out broadcast and
build workflows all these tasks are
easily done with active campaigns
so now let's discuss some pros of active
campaign
great automation feature that simplify
customer interaction helpful friendly
and fast customer support there are 850
plus integration with the most popular
software programs now let's discuss some
of its cons
challenging learning curve there are
several limitations with the light plant
including active campaign branding the
price of plants increases rapidly as the
number of contacts increases
so let's explore the different different
plans that active campaign has
if you see there is an option of how
much contact do you have so if you
increase that
right these plans will increase if you
see there are four plants light plus
professional and enterprise plant
so if number of contacts increases your
plant price will also increase if you
want to see the detailed features you
can go through uh the active campaign
pricing page and you will just explore
these different different features
the next tool on our list is mail and
light melee lite is one of the leading
email marketing and automation platform
the platform helps marketers design and
deliver engaging personalized email
campaigns it is the best tool to get all
the essentials at a lower price point
and provide a platform for small
businesses non-profit bloggers and
marketers to manage track and analyze
email campaigns the platform has email
templates email builders and
autoresponders drip campaigns and email
analytics
so let's discuss the pros of mail and
lite email can be designed easily with a
drag and drop interface a free plan for
up to 1000 contacts is available there
are a variety of email templates to
choose from
let's discuss some of its cons
it does not include crm functionality
through it allows for integration
active campaigns and others have
automation that can be triggered
directly from the website traffic which
is missing in melonlite
in order to set up an account a lot of
information about the company is needed
so now let's discuss the pricing of
miller lite miller lite also comes up
with four plans first plan is free so
you can get up to thousand subscribers
the same procedure for the billing
method is followed by the mailer light
as well
if you see if we scroll up once you
increase this number
the price of all the four plants will
increase and once you decrease the count
of subscribers the price will decrease
the plan will depends on the number of
subscribers once you increase that the
plan will automatically increase
the last enterprise plan is the custom
pricing for that you need to contact
them and their sales team will give you
a customized plan for you
another best email marketing tool is
hubspot hubspot is the best all-in-one
marketing suit as it has a great tools
and reporting of all your marketing
campaigns across various channels like
website social media email marketing and
many more it is best for b2b service
companies hubspot has an email marketing
tool that you can use to design
newsletters and send them to your
customers if you want to know how to use
the tool hubspot has a ton of resources
for you you will find lot of beginner
stuff there along with some advanced
steps if you want to get later more
technical hubspot also offers a
downloadable api
now let's discuss some of its pros
deliverability rates in check with email
health tabs pay only for those contacts
to whom you are marketing
a bunch of helpful online training
resources let's discuss some of its cons
it does not offer a free forever plan or
a lower cost plan it is not suitable for
businesses looking solely for email
marketing tools adding a separate crm
like salesforce is difficult
now let's discuss the hubspot pricing if
you go to the hubspot.com products slash
marketing slash email you will find this
email marketing tool section here you
can check out they have mentioned this
feature is available for free with
additional functionalities and premium
editors of marketing hub see the pricing
phase for more information so then we
just need to go into the pricing section
once we go into the pricing section you
can check out the different different
plans that hubspot offers under that you
will find email marketing as well so as
we discuss in the cons as well this tool
is not for someone or businesses looking
for only for email marketing services
because it offers more than just email
services
next is send in blue send in blue is one
of the most powerful email marketing
software you can use send in is best for
building your customer base in minutes
you can send email newsletters to
thousands of subscribers with its simple
interface and powerful features
sendinblue is designed for e-commerce
businesses retailers agencies and even
bloggers it has an easy to use interface
powerful features and a robust set of
tools that allow you to manage
subscribers database it can send any
type of email marketing ranging from
marketing newsletters to transactional
emails like order and shipping
confirmations now let's discuss some of
its pros
a wealth of transactional email and sms
features and includes basic crm
functionality
impressive range of automation and
integration
now let's discuss some of its cons
there is a daily limit of 300 emails per
day for the free plan setting up an
account for the first time can be
challenging there is a separate charge
for advanced template creation
so now let's have a look at the pricing
of sending blue if you see all the four
plants will come with unlimited contact
storage the first plan is free that also
comes with unlimited contacts so that is
the best thing about the sendinblue then
there is a light plan premium plan and
the enterprise plan if you want to get
some customized plan you can
click on this get code button and their
sales team will reach out to you and
they will create a custom plan for you
according to your needs you can contact
them
so now that we have covered five tools
does any tool satisfy your business
needs yet
let us know in the comment section below
get response get response is a
well-known email marketing service
provider it is an all-in-one marketing
solution that helps to manage track and
automate your email marketing campaigns
it has a simple drag and drop interface
and offers a wide range of features
getresponse provides a free plan that
startups can use to build their email
list it also offers features such as
automation split testing and landing
pages
let's discuss some of the get response
pros the webinar feature stands on its
own and eliminates the need for third
party webinar tools
fast website builder and ai design tools
now let's discuss some of its cons
in comparison with emails and landing
pages building forms is more limited and
intuitive maxplan subscribers only have
access to their dedicated customer
support
so now let's check out the get response
pricing if you see there are four plans
again the best part is that it also
offers a free plan where there is
unlimited newsletters one landing page
website builder connect your domain
signup forms and pop-ups so in free plan
you will get lot of stuffs also up to
500 contacts you can use in the free
plan then there are separate plans for
email marketing and then for
marketing automation in marketing
automation all the features that you
will get in email marketing you will
automatically get in the marketing
automation and some extra features that
you will get they are listed here if you
see on e-commerce marketing here also
all the features of free email marketing
and marketing automation will be there
plus there are some additional features
which you can explore here
next is convertkit nathan barry
discovered a new email marketing
software called convertkit for bloggers
creators and authors it's considered one
of the best email marketing solutions
now let's discuss some of its pros
the charge is based on the numbers of
unique subscribers you have you won't
get charged for duplicate subscribers
like mailchimp and ever
auto sending your broadcast may
automatically be resent if they have not
been opened now let's discuss some of
its cons
subscribers who are inactive are
automatically tagged gold by default
split testing is only possible for
subject lines not sender names and
sending times
so now let's check out the pricing of
convertkit if we scroll down on the
pricing page there are three plans as we
already discussed it is especially made
for creators and authors so there will
be three plans free greater and greater
proof
so in free you will get 300 subscribers
and if you
want to go with the greater plan then
you have to pay nine dollars per month
and 25 dollars per month for the creator
pro plan
and that is for the 300 subscribers only
if you increase this 300 subscribers
these numbers will automatically
increase on all the plans
but if you increase the count of the
subscribers these numbers will increase
automatically
on all the plans there is a very good
functionality that convertkit provides
that is unlimited landing pages even in
the
free plan also you will get unlimited
landing pages and unlimited forms and
unlimited email sending so that is a
very good thing
uh which convertkit provides
next is avabo
when you are trying to pick a service
for email marketing you want to be sure
you are picking a service that easy to
use and will provide you with a lot of
bang for your bunk
with aweber you can rest assured that
you are getting a lot of for your money
the services offers you a ton of
features including autoresponders and
email templates and it's all very easy
to use
in fact some people felt that the
service was too simple to use email
marketing can be intimidating to some
people but ever makes it simple
now let's discuss some of its pros with
so many pricing options no matter what
your budget is there is sure to be a
plant that fits your needs
if you use avabar you can offer your
subscribers a single opt in and double
opt an option
you can import files and email addresses
straight into an autoresponder cycle
let's discuss some of its cons landing
page builders are nice but a b testing
is not supported templates are available
in a wide variety but some are not
trendy with the standard emit builder
rss cannot be converted or edited into
email templates
now let's check out the pricing of ever
if you see there are two plans available
pro and average free average free plan
will offer you up to 500 email
subscribers landing pages web push
notifications drag and drop builders and
many more features so in free plan you
will get lot of stops but if you see
there is a pro plan
if you increase the number of
subscribers
then your
per month price will increase if you see
if i
have selected a subscriber range from
2500 to 5000 then it will cost me
46.15 dollars per month
so all the features that are available
in the free plan you will get in pro and
here are some additional features like
unlimited email list you can create
advanced email automation and many more
features you will get in the pro plan
the next tool is constant contact
constant contact is the leading provider
of marketing and communication products
for small businesses with constant
contact you can send beautiful emails
manage your contacts create a custom
blog and engage with your customers all
from one place whether you are starting
a business a non-profit or a blog
constant contact has the right tools
trainings and support to make your
business grow let's discuss some of its
pros landing pages logo makers and forms
and good deliverability
let's discuss some of its cons phone
support only on weekdays eastern time
automation can be difficult for
beginners
so let's discuss the constant contact
pricing so there will be two plants core
and plus so there is no free plan in the
constant contact in core plan you will
get some good features like custom list
chrome tools email marketing 300 plus
email templates and whatever you get in
core you will get in the plus plan
everything that you will get in core
plan you will automatically get in the
plus plan plus there are some additional
features that you will get in the plus
plan for example additional list growth
tools uh automated emails auto generated
segments
and personalized kick off call and
conversion sales and reporting and the
extra features that you will get in the
plus plan
the sender is another email marketing
tool you should consider sender is a
real-time email marketing automation
tool that allows marketers to send
personalized email to their customers at
a moment's notice the tool has a drag
and drop interface and a ton of features
including a b testing opt-in forms and a
variety of templates that can be
customized marketers can also send
automated follow-ups to their contacts
using their trip campaigns let's discuss
some of its pros it is easy to use
sender's interface and different
features the customer service department
is very active fast and resourceful
let's discuss some of its cons it may be
difficult to integrate with other
applications the payment process is not
straightforward and not very easy to
understand
so now let's
explore the sender pricing the best
thing about sender is it offers a free
forever plan you don't need to
invest a single rupees to get the basic
stuffs like you can get up to 2500
subscribers up to 15 000 emails per
month you can send email automation
features you will get contain sender
branding so if you don't want uh that
send branding then you can go with the
uh premium plans like standard
professional and enterprise plans and on
enterprise plan there is a custom price
that
once you reach out to their sales team
the sender's sales team you will get a
customized plan for you
so next is professional uh 29
it will cost you and the another plan is
standard that will cost you eight
dollars
in standard you will get 30k emails per
month and in professional plan you will
get 60k emails per month there are some
other features which you can explore by
going to the sender's pricing page
so as of now we have discussed several
tools let's have a look at a few more
email marketing tools benchmark best for
small agencies and consultants moscent
best affordable option campaign monitor
the best choice for creating
personalized emails email octopus the
best choice for web developers autopilot
best for advanced marketing automation
so we have explored 10 plus amazing
email marketing tools in this video
which tool do you think is best for your
business and why is that tool best you
can mention it in the comment section
below it will be helpful for others also
to know more about the tool
so with this we have come to the end of
this session on email marketing tools i
hope this session was informative and
exciting in case you have any questions
about any of the topics covered in this
session or if you need resources used in
this session then please feel free to
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of practitioners will be
more than happy to resolve your queries
at the earliest until next time this is
tushar from the simplyland team signing
off thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here